well what's been the most difficult
thing for you being in the spotlight
because I feel like you know I mean it's
been a year but it can't be that easy
walking around everywhere you go people
noticing you taking photos with you yeah
what's been the hardest part about that
for you I don't know people trying to
take me out people trying to take you
out yeah what do you mean oh yeah yeah
yeah you got hacked a lot in band and
hacked so much [ __ ] it's more people
targeting you yeah well even when you
walk through the airport people walk up
to you yeah paparazzi's something
happened at your house a bunch of [ __ ]
of like what you're from the beach walk
jump in the fence
yeah people come on the property try to
[ __ ] with me
yell I mean a bunch of [ __ ] but I gotta
buy a house soon that has like electric
fences yeah
high voltage yeah it's time it's time to
for you to invest in some real estate a
trench yeah a moat a giant moat with
Gators some big Gators in it I'll be
fire you did just invest in some real
estate that didn't you you bought a
building yeah what's that all about what
are you doing with it
I haven't I can't really discuss of what
my plans are what's something crazy
something crazy besides just building
spongebob giant spongebob houses in the
back Bikini Bottom in the backyard Jack
he's [ __ ] crazy he's going the same
with all that [ __ ] yeah my brother's
always building some random [ __ ]
sometimes I got tell me get off my
property god dammit [ __ ] bunch of like
laundry machines and garbage really
there's a few beat cars there now oh my
god yeah that's why I drove my bus and
uh
into one of the cars you drove your bus
into one of the cars yeah
nice in the parking lot I was tired of
it being there so I just ran into yeah
full speed
what's up with the big [ __ ] it pink tea
that you painted on the front of it is
that just for tea foo I don't know or
you just haven't finished painting it
dick just painted it on there cuz he's
[ __ ] weird I'm gonna paint the whole
[ __ ] because it looks just discussed